what do you got in there
what do you got in there now what do you
got in there what do you got there oh
newly released body camera video shows a
deadly shooting in Colorado after a
woman allegedly pulled a gun at an
officer who fatally shot her I'm so
sorry I'm so sorry
I'm so sorry it was just before 5 PM on
July 25th when a Westminster Colorado
officer noticed an SUV parked in the
road facing the wrong direction video
shows him approach a forward-facing Jeep
asking what's going on
thank you
[Music]
hi there
okay just how long you been here
okay I'll get them done I'll see what's
up the officer Nick Adams Then
approaches the parked vehicle The woman
Inside later identified as 46 year old
Alicia Duran initially refuses to roll
down the window
[Music]
[Applause]
impact
eventually Duran gives in and puts the
window down but refuses to answer the
officer's questions you're in the wrong
lane
are you okay
are you okay man
what's going on tell me what's going on
are you okay
atoms can be heard asking whether she's
okay and calling in the situation on His
Radio
[Applause]
can you tell me what's going on why are
you in the wrong lane
can you tell me why you're in the wrong
way
I don't know what I got here I got a
female that won't answer any questions I
think I'm in our vet I'm in our turn
lane to go into the shops if you want to
start one of them Duran only replies
when the officer asks whether she needs
an ambulance what's going on
can you tell me what's going on now
please
are you okay do you need an ambulance
are you all right
okay when he asks if she's been drinking
she reverts back to silence
I haven't been drinking or anything
it doesn't look like
it's then that Duran reaches for
something in her middle console Adams
can be heard asking her what it is
before realizing it's a gun what do you
got in there
what do you got
in there Adams grabs her arm before
backing off and shooting at her what do
you got in there what have you got there
oh
immediately Adams puts out a shots fired
call and yells for Duran to stay still
225 shots fired shots fired
don't move
are you okay are you okay when backup
arrives at the scene Adams removes the
gun from the vehicle where Duran is
already unresponsive I've got the gun
secured
no response from her
people downrange
appear to be code for let's get her out
of the car you get the gun I'll get her
out of the car yeah I'm trying to do all
that man give me a minute you grab the
gun I got her
just get that out of here
[Applause]
I don't think so
I got no pulse
then approaches the Jeep parked nearby
asking if everyone inside is okay are
you all right
are you okay no one inside the jeep was
injured but a bullet hit the windshield
atoms can be heard apologizing to the
people inside before breaking down
are you okay
I'm so sorry I'm so sorry
I was so sorry
[Music]
I'm so sorry I'm so sorry he continues
on explaining what happened just moments
before
she wouldn't talk to me she just she had
some
some like charm or something and she
wouldn't talk to me I said do you need
an ambulance what do you need and she
reached into the center console and I
saw these guns and pointed it right at
me I was so worried I was gonna shoot
down range at you oh my God the person
inside the vehicle then identifies
themselves as Jess and Adams introduces
himself again apologizing what name
just
you're fine you don't need an ID Jess
I'm Nick okay you're gonna need to stick
around for us a little while I
[Music]
you can I'll give you my work phone you
can call whoever you need we'll we'll
get we'll get somebody to talk to her
okay hold on a minute I'm consoling her
man I put one right to her window okay
okay she's okay are you okay I'm okay
I'm gonna secure this gun I'm gonna give
her my work phone so she can make sure
all right another officer approaches
checking whether Adams is okay
yeah
yeah sure yeah yeah yeah yeah come and
go pick this man come look at this next
Adams introduces Jess to the other
officer before making a bizarre remark
about America
it's just this is my best buddy Mark are
you okay are you okay the steering wheel
it's a birthday oh oh okay it's America
God Bless America I'm so sorry oh my God
stay right here there's my phone okay
next atoms can be seen holding hands
with another officer who appears to be
comforting him
seconds later another officer instructs
Adams to turn off his body camera video
I've got the gun in my car Serge you
want me to get Mark to take the gun with
us uh Oregon
leave it in my car it's in the cup
holder okay
look at me let's do this
go off
off
Duran died as a result of her injuries
as the investigation is still ongoing
Adams has been placed on paid
administrative leave her Department
policy reporting for long crime Network
I'm Sierra Gillespie